what is the hardest part of writing for
you
i think at least at least for me
um you need to have a lot of discipline
to write and i i remember
because i visited um his house in
key west that like ernest hemingway like
he would have
uh a practice of like no matter what he
would always
like you know block out like four or
five hours in the morning
to write no matter what he would do that
every single day
you know some days he would write a lot
some days he would just write like two
words but he would always block out
those hours
to write and so i think that that's
maybe the hardest thing is you know
really maintaining
that discipline and that self motivation
because writing can be kind of lonely
how many hours a day do you write do you
do the same thing
i have to say that i'm not as
disciplined as ernest
i think it was um because
i need what i really need to do is i
need to like turn off my phone
because i get very easily distracted
like if i get a message or if i get a
phone call
and what i need to do is i need to be
completely focused and then i can just
kind of plow through
pages that way
do you set goals for yourself definitely
i'll be like okay
you know i know i i need to get like 30
pages by the end of this week
so you know i work out okay so i'll do
do five this day six this day maybe this
day i'll do four so then the next day i
can do so so i
i definitely try and like uh figure out
what my
my daily goals are to work to the big
goal when you write your first draft of
something
what's your next step do you put it away
do you
send it to somebody that you know will
give you honest maybe brutal feedback
but what is your plan with that i think
so if i finish writing the first draft
i like to put it away for a little bit
and try and create a space
where i have like a little bit more
objectivity and then i read it
see if there's anything that i want to
change and if i'm like
no i think i want to show this now then
i'll send it to someone
whose opinion i really value
and have you ever been critical of
something you've written and then you've
given it space and then you go you know
what wow this is actually great
i was too hard on myself or or maybe
vice versa i don't know
i mean i never
i mean all i can really gauge is how
much
i enjoyed writing it and i i tend to
find that the things that
i enjoyed writing more are the ones that
i get
better feedback um about
but i think that um definitely i've
i've had treatments that i've asked
notes
for and gotten very like critical notes
like pretty brutal
feedback and i've worried that like oh
maybe this is just really bad and i
should scrap
it but then i'm like okay i'm gonna try
again
and then i've applied with that same
treatment for
fellowships and like gotten in to those
so it just goes to show that even if
maybe it starts badly that doesn't mean
that it can't
you know end a bit better
you've directed many short films but
this was your first feature
were there like one or two things that
you were totally surprised at
as a first-time feature film director
that you thought
wouldn't happen or it was just new to
you
because you're doing a longer format i
think
that you know we definitely had some
some things come up that couldn't have
been predicted there were like
there was a weekend that we had to
postpone shooting because there was
the a heat wave like a really kind of
you know terrible heat wave in
la at the time and that's something that
it's like
usually usually with a short film like
you know if you shoot for like five days
you're usually
you're able to do those those five days
in a row and if you have to postpone
it's maybe not that big
a deal but we were lucky that on the
feature that happened more towards the
end of the shoot
because i think if it had happened like
in the beginning or in the middle i
think it would have been really
catastrophic to like um recover
a rhythm and i think that's the most
important thing i think i found that
more in the future than i did on the
short was like how important for there
to be like a rhythm
that's being established and how you
know how you do eventually become a very
well-oiled
machine after like you know two weeks of
working together
so that even when things don't go
according to plan and you do have to
postpone
it's it's okay because when you when you
do
come back together it's you're already
so used to
working with each other that you can
just pick up where you left off
oh wow i hadn't thought of that that's
really interesting
so it takes it takes a few weeks to kind
of get to know
people's styles not just their
personality but their like working
styles
and really like gel together yeah
so then when this heat wave occurred how
many days did that take out of the
production we still had um
two more full days
um and i think a half day that we needed
to do
so even though it was you know
i mean it wasn't great that we had to to
push back and we ended up losing our dp
because he had already booked another
shoot it could have been worse
you